i really believe that a good leader is
someone that
you know you're only as good as what you
make someone else so i
i started really making sure that the
people that i bring on board to speak in
front of the rooms to be
the ones that managing those offices
right first of all you gotta trust them
but second of all you gotta really
develop them to have everything you can
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford we're going to talk about
building revenue and growth in a small
startup and scaling it
meet elon brenner the chief revenue
officer and general manager of u.s
operations of sensei ai
sensei ai is an award-winning first of
its kind ai solution that is designed to
resolve
challenges in the elder care industry
and give your loved ones the opportunity
to age with dignity
confidence happiness and safety he is
also the founder of legion inc
where he was also the ceo from 2008 to
a company focused on specialized
marketing services from the ground up to
today overseeing an organization
with over 600 employees in 30 offices
alon brenner welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
great great thank you for having me i
appreciate it i love the sun behind you
where are you in the world right now
uh i'm in the bay area i'm in danville
california in the east bay
i i love it i'm jealous i'm i am sitting
here in tel aviv which
you should be jealous and especially as
bars have just opened
uh right downstairs so if you hear some
noise that's coming from everything here
so
a little victory for us but alone today
we have a few things that
and that i'm truly truly excited to talk
about all the way from
uh you know sales teams within a small
startup sensei ai which is doing
remarkable work
very impactful work but you as the chief
revenue officer
now growing that business and
transitioning to high-tech sales teams
but
but really your your vast experience in
that for i believe 12 years running the
organization
legion and and doing some phenomenal
work over there
and and some personal achievements that
have
made you a a figure to to
give advice to people on something
that's a little sensitive
a lot personal but really really
meaningful so
we'll start from whichever one you feel
like alone so
take me to that subject and let's dive
in
all right thank you so i i think the
best way is to give you a little
overview a brief intro
and overview about myself i came to
america about 18 years ago
i worked in a couple of different
directions until i
in my background i'm a basketball player
i'm an athlete so i
really wanted to dive in some kind of a
sports background
so i started a sports and entertainment
marketing firm in the worst time you can
start a company in 2008
and i i didn't really know what to do i
started with like five people
and and uh in the bay area and and then
slowly
grew to uh what it is legion today with
uh
you know over 600 employees in 30
different cities
um and yeah we grew from sports
entertainment marketing leisure telecom
all industries we even work with
government we work with a lot of
different
uh clients and i'm humbled every year to
look back and see the growth of the
company and and what has happened with
it
um and then after i became a father i
started from humble beginnings i didn't
come for money and
and i always thought that israeli coming
to america to accomplish the american
dream i need to become this
this you know successful person and once
i reached that
that goal i really felt like something
was missing inside and and
i'm a father so i wanted to bring the
example to my children of
uh and also to create something a little
bit better for the world
more for a safer and and more
just in general better for the world and
a couple years ago i started
investing in consulting in early stage
startups and in technology companies
uh mostly israelis but not only in
israelis
and and mo and investing mostly in
companies that
create a better and safer world for
anywhere from teenagers
kids as well as elder care
about a year ago i was introduced as a
possible
investor possible consultant which i
ended up doing both uh to send cai
um and it was like love at first sight
and by the way today it's uh
international women's day so i want to
give a shout out to our ceo lomi
she's a you know female founder
unbelievable ceo
uh one of the things that really sold me
to get into this company was
was uh homie's intensity and excitement
and
and really wanted to make a difference
in the world
which really fit with my long-term goals
um
so i gave myself that age where i'm
gonna step down as a ceo from legion
and jump into a c-level executive
in a different company more tech so from
low-tech to high-tech
and i was able to really fall in love
with it with the crew with the
incredible crew incredible team and
incredible technology and i really
believe we're doing amazing things
in an industry that is extremely needing
this this uh this help so so hopefully
a few sentences about
sorry excuse me a few sentences about
sensei ai
what you guys are doing because it
really is highly impactful and i can
you know i understand why you're so
excited as you jump on this amazing ship
yeah so sensei ai is an ai solution we
created in order to
resolve the challenges in the elder care
industry um
to be able to allow the home care
agencies
um assisted living communities nursing
homes provide the highest quality of
care at all times
while minimizing the owner's liability
in that business
increase their new customer acquisition
new client acquisition
help with them with the assessment of
the caregiver and client satisfaction
and the retention of of of manpower
because in that industry there's a
shortage of manpower and it's such an
effective
job that you really want to bring the
highest quality of caregiver
for our loved ones so they could you
know
age in in a with with dignity and
respect and
and what we do basically is we really um
we were able through a tool to remove
all blind spot and give the owners
a complete transparency to each and
every hour of care
um that way they could really see what
goes on in each and every shift and get
an objective overview of what goes on
without having to rely on anyone's
opinion or output like the caregiver or
the client it just gives them the
ability
to know what goes on so we produce
notifications
and and we're able to really help these
brands produce the highest level of care
and we've seen
amazing increases from our eye
to to to quality of care to agencies
that use our services
are just becoming completely dominating
in their marketplace so it's been so
exciting and the feedback is incredible
literally uh you know improving people's
lives and
improving the lives of a population that
unfortunately
is just being totally underserved in the
21st century i'm
shocked i'm appalled and saying that you
know the frustration that i have to deal
with as
i look for solutions for my own you know
for the for the caring of my own
grandparents and i'm shocked that we
have
these you know this amazing world around
us yet
nothing is adapted for them and that
goes
both in the in the caring industry for
them but also in in you know the
facilities but but also inside the home
so i think that what you're doing with
sensei ai
is completely inspiring take me to that
moment where
you're an investor and you're you're
you're helping them
and you just you make that transition
what is that like is it
it does it does is it because of a
conversation you have with
with with the founder or is it a long
process
is it coming from your internal feeling
how does this whole thing work
tangibly well part of my goal was to
move from
from low tech to high tech regardless
but i've been i've
i've had many negotiations and many
conversations with a lot of companies
and i remember talking to to our ceo
homie and and one of the conversations
and she had the confidence of saying
along
why don't you join us into a call with a
client why don't you
see how it really is and i got to to
jump on a call
and speak one-on-one i was supposed to
be a fly on the wall but i got to speak
with a client a major client
and and i got to see that i'm i'm
capable of bringing such a value
not only in selling a product or a
service
but really understanding eye to eye
level of a business owner to a business
owner and we were able to onboard that
client and he really helped me
like not only were doing better for the
world not only
the message and the mission statement of
the companies that really
but i was able to really communicate
with the business owner at a high level
which brings a huge value
more than just selling something does
that make sense
a hundred percent and so you join in the
startup you go
you're saying from low tech to high tech
and now you're thinking okay wow
how do i you know how do i grow this
monster how do i
you know lead this ship lead the revenue
cycle lead the sales teams
where do you even start what do you do
as the leader
so so i believe that a leader makes his
people
make him a leader and currently you know
uh
the the u.s side of the team is is is
growing
and and we're in a position where you
know i'm gonna do a good job
if i build myself into that role of the
ce
the cro and the and the in the gm of the
u.s operation so for me
um the title is something that i'm going
to build myself because right now i do
everything from
entry-level work all the way up to a
c-level executive
i do everything you know because that's
i understand the nature of what it means
to build a business
from the ground up and when we came into
to the u.s marketplace
i had to really figure that out and and
also
uh what i've learned which i see as i
consult a lot of you know both
israeli startups israeli you know um
um technology companies and american
companies
uh but mostly israelis is the transfer
when they try to penetrate to the u.s
market
um it doesn't matter how good they are
in sales it doesn't matter how good they
speak english
they need to learn how to speak american
they need to learn how to speak
you know in that language
with that level of of uh communication
that unless you live here
breathier and and and let the american
culture really absorb in your system
you're not able to
deliver your message the same way so i
think that's the edge that i bring not
only to since the ai
when i do consult other companies is
really speaking eye level
in what i call america not just english
so
it gave me you know two three short tips
for an israeli myself coming to america
and uh like what are the big some some
differences that you're saying like yeah
like this
this might not be so obvious this might
not be something that
you know a typical technologists
will automatically have intuition for
i i think it's just letting them talk
and and
learning how to communicate with them
right both on a personal level
uh some small talk figure out a little
bit about them before you go and talk to
them figure
and figure out a little bit of a piece
of information that will make them
you know feel appreciated
um don't be uh i
i think that the israeli aggressiveness
is is really good
in in sales but before you get to
implement it
into sales you really gotta you gotta
really
do a process of getting to know your
client getting to know the person you're
talking to
um and and see see
what kind of person sits in front of you
before you you bring that israeli
mentality that always works
but you gotta really dose it the right
way if you know what i'm saying i hope i
answered your question
a hundred percent
i i think that i'd like to add to that
that it's it's you know the israelis
is fantastic but you know they are you
need to
modify it a little bit and to adapt it
to to the american culture so it's not
exactly you know one to one
and i remember that i walked into a
stanford business school class
where the lecturer is of course israeli
and he's trying to explain to the 500
students
the differences between the cultures and
it was uh hilarious
uh in one level i don't know if not
israelis understood it but it was
hilarious
and i completely understand what you're
saying here alone
what i'd love to do is also understand a
little bit better about
your experience with legion you're in
and you understand that you have a
natural talent for
for marketing and for messaging and for
people
and you grow this business for 12 years
can you give me a short rundown of what
this was like for you as a
you know from a small business owner to
a big business owner and
you know living through the business
from inception
to what it became
i i i can't get into too many details
here but i'll tell you that that when i
when i built legion i i learned what it
is to scale a business from being the
king of the pond to the king of the sea
to the king of the ocean
and the challenges that it comes with
you know having so many employees
and then and then growing an
organization and then having to manage
multiple locations and then
you know the art of delegating you know
delegating and really trusting that that
your people can do
you know uh good too so so i really
believe that a good leader is someone
that
you know you're only as good as what you
make someone else so i started really
making sure that the people that i bring
on board to speak in front of the rooms
to be
the ones that managing those offices
right first of all you gotta trust them
but second of all you gotta really
develop them to have everything you can
you know add tools on their skill set
and bring everything you possibly can
in order to increase the value that they
bring and really develop leaders leaders
of men and women and
and that really created the scaling of
the business but with every
domination of of a certain level i feel
like i learned a lot
a lot because it was it's just it's
extremely difficult and extremely
challenging
um i think to compete in that level
i i completely understand today and
honestly
i'm just excited to to one day
experience this growth hopefully for
myself you know
that that transition that you have to
make in your mind and that
you know that that amazing inertia and
and
that also i'm sure that it's scary on a
lot of levels as you're growing and
people are looking up to you sort of as
the vision leader but you know
it's practically every day you're doing
things that you've never done before
so your job just get you know it never
gets easier because you just
keep having to do new things so you know
you never get to really settle down
but alone you know we're talking about
leadership here at the show is called
20 minute leaders and leadership is not
just in the workforce
it's not just you know with your teams
and it's not just
as you're increasing the the revenue
channels for
for this amazing organization it's also
back home and in your community so tell
me a little bit about you know the
special circumstance
that you found yourself in and how
you're working with your with your
community
to help empower them with that
okay great question well for me
leadership today in this part of my life
i mean it was different 10 15 years ago
and now in my life
for me leadership is being a father and
and and really i have two amazing
children and
leadership for me is the example that i
bring them and it translates in the form
of what i do on my
personal time to give back and it's
something that happened kind of like
by mistake you know when i i'm a single
dad and when me and my ex-wife split
um my biggest commitment was to be the
you know
the best ex-husband i could ever be and
to really co-parent
at the best way possible in order to be
a great example for my children and to
provide them a
you know kind of like a stress-free
egoless environment
um and my ex-wife got married i was a
part of the wedding and it was amazing
and and as
of then i started really coaching and
and consulting to a lot of personally to
a lot of private people that came to me
and asked along
how are you able to manage you know
without being upset about the past
and and i was able to really do that and
it's funny because clubhouse
just started and i and i get to speak
about it and run rooms in clubhouse as
well about co-parenting
about really put your ego aside because
the most important part
is is your children and the example you
bring to your children
and you know maybe we didn't work out as
as as a married couple but we are
family and we're bonded for life so
that's the most important no matter what
happens in the past you got to look
forward
and i always say you know we're at point
a and this is point b
and we're gonna get from point a to
point b no matter what but we can take
the low way or we can take the highway
and if you take the high road
it's a lot more positive a lot less
drama and
and that's the best that i can help from
a personal perspective to anyone in my
life
um to to to just put away the anger put
away the ego
and so i do think it's some sort of
leadership because my kids are so proud
that their parents are so close uh
because they see other situations where
they go to school where they talk to
their friends
i i have to say that i think this is you
know the most important form of
leadership perhaps that i've heard over
400 episodes and i'm not i'm not just
saying that because
you know it's a it's one thing to lead
you know
when when you know you're looking at
something objective and and you know you
say yes we can do this we can do that
how about we delegate this but at the
end when it comes down to these you know
personal experiences and nothing
can be more personal than family nothing
can be more personal than kids
or you know unfortunately a failed
marriage and
you know you're saying you're you're
talking here you know confidently and as
if it's
easy but i'm sure that it's incredibly
difficult i'm sure that it's like
it's a continuous challenge even if it
becomes easier over time i'm sure that
it still is a challenge because
there's just a wealth of history over
there that you know just doesn't get
erased it just doesn't happen but
but the ability to uh to take this
scenario and understand that
you know at the end you're still gonna
get to the same place and you can either
serve as a role model or you can
not and and choose to be that role model
that i think is the most exciting form
of leadership so i don't i i already
gained everything that i need to gain
from this episode thank you already
what are you most excited about in in
right now
obviously your kids but you know when
you look at the world
and where you are what is the group for
something that really gets you going
um you know i've i've
i'll share that i just turned 40. i
don't know if that's something that
people share here but
i turned 40 but for the longest time i
said i told my employees i told my kids
i told everyone that my 40s are going to
be monumental they're going to be great
and i've kind of hit the restart button
on a lot of things i've started a new
journey
from a career perspective i think that
everything i touch right now in my life
is to not just do good for myself is to
do good for the world
being the best example for my children
continue traveling with them
um i don't know i'm excited about life
i'm excited i'm hyped about
about where i am in my life um without
getting into too many personal details i
think i think uh
i'm super excited about the next decade
and where it's going to take me
and that's pretty much it when it comes
to
to that well elon i'm just excited that
i get to now be a tiny tiny part of that
of that next decade so thank you for the
opportunity thank you for coming here
thank you for giving me your time
and and for giving me this inspiration
and i just can't wait
for for for me and my friends to watch
this and re-watch this
because i think that the lessons to be
taken from here are
you know timeless and long-standing
before we leave alone
i have the most important question which
is three words you would use to describe
yourself
father that's for sure always so
father um achiever
i think that i just you know i'll keep
it short achiever it's pretty
self-explanatory and um
motivational i think i have this the the
ability to to motivate people if i'm
passionate about something that i'm
speaking about so
those are the three words that come to
mind it only took 20 minutes i
i can imagine what days could do
alone thank you very very much i'll see
you for a beer
in the bay area when i'm back and until
then
stay safe more than welcome you're more
more than welcome thank you brother
[Music]